hey leute herzlich willkommen zum
heutigen video ford mercury dass das
licht so doof ist und das ist so heiß
ich bin bei luca gerade und er schneidet
ein video in dem raum wo die soft und
das gute licht steht und deshalb macht
dafür 4
wo soll ich anfangen wie bestimmt viele
verbieten bin ich letztlich umgezogen
und zwar nach köln und das mein erster
umzug beziehungsweise meine erste eigene
wohnung und es läuft alles wie vor und
ich habe irgendwie festgestellt dass
irgendwie jeder
besonders lustig findet wenn bei mir was
schief läuft deshalb dachte ich mir ich
erzähle euch heute wenigstens mal was
ich alles verbockt habe und was alles
schiefgelaufen ist die letzten wochen
aber um selbst ein bisschen dampf
abzulassen und damit ihr euch darüber
amüsieren können weil heute morgen ist
wieder passierte und auf twitter sagte
jeder darüber nacht ab also bitte weiß
schadenfroh wirtschaftlicher so begehen
wir mal mit einer sehr frühen geschichte
das war einer der ersten abend wenn ich
der erste abend oder tag den ich in
meiner wohnung verbracht habe und
erreichen mit meinem bruder bei mir in
der wohnung und wir haben irgendwas
eingekauft das auto kurz und vor dem
haus geparkt nicht parken darf ein
kopftuch getragen und es dann um geparkt
so dann kommen wir wieder zurück
einkäufe waren ja von oben dass veh ich
habe den schlüssel drin gelassen da
musste ich wirklich super eigentlich da
musste ich am ersten oder an einem der
ersten tage in meiner wohnung den
schlüsseldienst rufen und 100 euro
bezahlen damit die tür geöffnet wird
bitter also richtig bitter und dumm aber
ja ich hatte keine ahnung was alles noch
kommen bürger genießt musste ich dann
auch so logischer weil ich in youtube
muss ich mich dann auch zeitnah darum
kümmern das internet in meiner neuen
wohnung habe habe ich einfach mal
anrufen bei ein paar internet und
telefonanbietern und habe mich dann für
einen entschieden ich will jetzt einfach
mal keine namen auf jeden fall der
anbieter für diejenigen die in china hat
mit mir einen termin ausgemacht wagen
immer in drei fragen und hat ihm gesagt
hör an dem tag zwischen
18 und 19 uhr kommt der techniker zu
ihnen und schließt alles an
daher können wir machen ich musste dann
halt weil ich davor zu hause war extra
250 kilometer anreisen aber etwas
deutsch internet er ist schon so dann
gleich dort und habe dann irgendwie noch
einen tag vorher eine bestätigung
bekommen und in der bestätigung stammt
die techniker kommt zwischen 12 uhr und
19 uhr und ich hab mir so hell dass
zwischen 18 und 19 uhr kommen und aus
dem zeitfenster von einer stunde wurden
mal eben sieben stunden und ihr könnt
euch vorstellen das ist halt mega essen
weil ich hab den ganzen tag bis zu möge
häusern fahren und möbel in meine
wohnung schaffen damit das halt
irgendwie alles langsam voll wird und
dann kommt es im extrem ungelegen wenn
ich den ganzen tag zu hause warten musst
so ich mache mir die kurzfassung war ich
ja noch mehr es soll ich habe auf jeden
fall habe ich da an den ganzen tag
gewartet und zweimal den tag über
anrufen bei der hotline von diesem
internetanbieter beide male wurde mir
gesagt der kunden techniker ist gerade
in dem gespräch und er würde aber auf
jeden fall noch zu mir kommen und dann
habe ich um 1930 noch mal angerufen und
dann ruft einer anderen tag mit
tatsächlich oh das tut mir aber leid bei
uns im system steht der war heute schon
um 12 uhr da hat am verteilerkasten
nachgeschaut und konnte ihn aber nicht
finden also megaupload und ich habe den
ganzen tag gewartet aber schon sorgen
auslassen ich glaube ihr könnt euch
vorstellen aber war echt nicht schön
dann habe ich halt bei dem
internetanbieter angerufen hat eine
beschwerde eingereicht und dann wurde
sich auch vernünftig um mich gekümmert
weshalb ich jetzt auch keinen namen
genannt habe das war die nächste story
da hatte ich dann auf jeden fall ist
meine ich war dann ungefähr sieben tage
in meiner wohnung ohne das internet
hatte und ich meine es ist
wahrscheinlich für euch alle schon
schlimm aber für mich der halter mit
erarbeitet und so ist es noch ein tick
schlimmer kommen vom nächsten story
durch hat so die ersten paar tage in
meiner wohnung geschlafen ich meine das
ist ja ein bisschen über zwei wochen
erst fertig umgezogen bin in diesem
zeitraum hat sich das alles ereignet ich
habe die ersten paar mal in meiner
wohnung geschlafen und irgendwann klappt
es dann morgens und der mieter unter mir
haben worauf das bietet schöne grüße
oder meinte er er wollte mich nur mal
darauf hinweisen man hört
alles was ich oben in der wohnung über
ihm mache und er das nicht gesagt weil
ich irgendwie beschwert oder mac oder so
sondern einfach weil ich meine es muss
sehr bedrückend sein wenn man einfach
jedes wort mit hört was da jemand
spricht und das wollte mich einfach
wissen lassen uns meinen das war
logischerweise auch kein schönes gefühl
und seitdem überlege ich immer viel was
kannst noch rein stellt damit die
akustik ein bisschen besser ist und dass
man nicht so viel hört und so und
irgendwie ist das auch ein bisschen blöd
im hinterkopf zu haben ja das wird nicht
so die größte story aber es ist schon
nervig und jetzt kommen wir zu heute
leute heute war echten tag irgendwann
angefangen zu sich zu finden so vieles
schiefgelaufen verrät nicht die große
geschichte um eine waschmaschine
es hieß ich könnte aus der
verwandtschaft eine waschmaschine haben
die 34 jahre alt ist und die wein soling
sodann mich nach solingen gefahren
testet was über dort mir zu helfen
dann waren wir bei der waschmaschine
überall tauchen dann habe ich auf die
rechnung geschaut mal war die
waschmaschine 13 jahre alt statt drei
jahren und was maschinen werden
logischerweise nicht so alte zeit
gewähren in den nächsten paar monaten
kaputt gegangen das heißt kette warum
sonst gekommen ich war umsonst gekommen
alles umsonst immer dann habe ich mir
online eine bestell und das hat jetzt
ein paar tage gedauert und jetzt wurde
wie heute morgen geliefert auch wieder
zwischen 7 und 11 uhr wann kommen sie um
4 45 uhr aufgestanden
so oder so die waschmaschine wurde
geliefert die leute von der spedition
haben die waschmaschine hochgetragen
mich hat nicht durch die tür und die
waschmaschine hat einfach nicht durch
die tür gesetzt bevor er sagt du bist
aber komplett um was die tür nicht
gemessen oder sonst was
ich habe die tür gemessen aber online wo
ich die waschmaschine gekauft habe waren
einfach die falschen maße angegeben und
das ist jetzt echt kein scheiß oder so
waren ein bis zwei zentimeter die
gefehlt haben dass sich die
waschmaschinen durch die türe kompakt
logischerweise habe ich die tür
ausgehängt und so war es hat einfach
nicht vom jetzt und jetzt kommt der clou
die sind dann einfach ganz schnell
abgezogen haben gesagt okay dann klappt
das nicht tut uns leid lassen sei was
die waschmaschine ihr beim nächsten mal
bringen wir wieder mit und boom waren
sie aus der tür und ich war voll
überrumpelt weil ich davon so kiefer
die waschmaschine ist und dann waren die
weg und die waschmaschinen stand bei mir
im eingangsbereich so der
eingangsbereich in meiner wohnung ist
ziemlich klein und jetzt habe ich da bis
sich eine neue waschmaschine bestellen
akkurt wird eine waschmaschine rumstehen
dass ich den tag noch irgendwie nutzen
und wenn mit luca zusagen zu ikea
gefahren und was mir zeit dass hier
richtig meine playstation 4 wurde
geliefert konnte nicht abgegeben werden
deshalb kann ich sie mir irgendwann die
nächsten tagen bei der post abholen aber
leute
falls dieses video neben einem mich
aufregen und eurer schadenfreude
irgendwie funktion haben soll
dann bleibt irgendwie immer positiv ich
meine ich habe jetzt tatsächlich
angefangen die sachen lustig zu finden
weil so viel mist irgendwie passiert
endlich mal scheiße läuft dann tretet
einen schritt zurück und vielleicht
stellte fest das ist so scheiße läuft
das schon wieder das ticket okay das
war's vom heutigen video ich wollte es
mal erzählen wir sehen uns dann morgen
oder übermorgen wieder und bis dahin
tschüss